asset prices have been crashing and
there's a lot of investors wondering
what's going to happen in the future
well we can use history as a guide
doesn't necessarily tell us exactly
what's going to happen but it sure does
give us a lot of context chris dixon is
one of those investors who's been around
through multiple market cycles he
recently had a tweet thread that
explained exactly what his thoughts were
around the 2008 global financial crisis
and how it had an impact on various
technologies and companies that were
built here he starts it off and he says
there's a lot of talk lately about the
possibility of a prolonged financial
downturn reminiscent of 2008 2008 was a
difficult time for many many people but
from a startup perspective 2008 and the
following three years turned out to be a
golden age apple released the iphone in
2007 and the app store in 2008 by 2009
talented founders they were pouring in
most of today's top mobile apps were
created by companies founded between
2009 and 2011 including uber venmo snap
and instagram in retrospect that era was
propelled by a combination of three
powerful trends social media cloud
computing and the rise of smartphones
independent product design spaces are
multiplicative even if social cloud and
mobile each improved linearly the
combination could improve exponentially
chris included this chart that he made
to think about product and financial
cycles and what he's done here is he's
overlaid the nasdaq index with the key
projects and companies and their
founding dates and then this idea of
product cycles everything from the
incubation phase all the way through to
the growth phase chris then went on to
talk about the key idea is that product
and financial cycles evolve mostly
independently the top of the chart shows
the nasdaq index as a rough proxy for
financial sentiment financial sentiment
fluctuates unpredictably and sometimes
wildly the next row shows the years that
iconic startups or products were created
the timing is mostly dictated by product
cycles which are shown in that bottom
row product cycles follow their own
internal logic and tend to be more
predictable than financial cycles
they begin with an incubation phase in
which enthusiasts explore ideas and
build products that are mostly used by
other enthusiasts for example there were
credible attempts to create smartphones
as early as 1990. smartphones continued
to advance for the next 15 years but it
wasn't until after the iphone launch
that they transitioned from the
incubation to the growth phase the
growth phase starts when the right mix
of technology talent and community
knowledge comes together it's driven by
reinforcing feedback loop between
infrastructure and applications for
example as the iphone improved better
apps were possible better apps helped
drive iphone sales giving apple more
money to invest enabling even better
apps and so on the tech industry is very
different today than it was in 2008 a
handful of tech incumbents dominate the
internet exerting vast economic and
cultural influence entrenched interest
aggressively respond to new movements
that might someday threaten them he
believes that krypto and web3 will be at
the center of the next cycle that
they've reached a critical mass of
technology talent and community
knowledge in the almost 10 years since
he's been involved in the space the
energy and creativity has never been
higher chris then goes on to talk about
if we are headed for an economic
downturn there are some tactical lessons
from the 2008 era namely preserving
capital and staying focused on your
long-term vision but the main lesson is
to ignore the noise and stay squarely
focused on the product cycle so i think
that chris has got some really
interesting ideas here and many of them
i agree with as you look across market
cycles both up and down what you find is
it the best companies they continue to
innovate they continue to release
products and many times in the bear
markets that's actually where the true
value gets built and eventually starts
to grow into some sort of growth phase
at the end of the day no one knows
what's going to happen in the future we
don't know where many of these
technologies are going to be built which
ones will be adopted on a global basis
and what the actual impact of the
innovation is but what we do know is
that the market cycles are a natural
part of how the world works there are
good times and there are bad times
there's reasons why we get the good
times and there's reasons why we get the
bad times if you want to spend most of
your time trying to analyze why the good
and bad times happen you can do that but
the builders they'll be busy building
actual technology and trying to innovate
trying to figure out what are the
products that we can now create that
previously weren't possible at the end
of the day when people get into bear
markets it usually brings out two
different types of people some people
are trolls and they simply end up
attacking everyone else others are
builders and they put their heads down
they focus and they start creating more
and more value one of the beautiful
parts of bear markets is that they
always end and at the end of the bear
market what we find is who was doing the
work and who was just chirping on the
internet as we continued to watch this
bear market play out looking back in
2008 in the 2000 tech bubble or many
other market cycles that came before it
we can learn a lot of different lessons
but what you find is that many of those
lessons are timeless make sure that you
have the capital to weather the storm
make sure you stay focused on actually
building true innovation and creating
products that people love and last but
not least don't worry about all the
noise
whenever we go into bear markets all the
critics they come out and they're loud
they start celebrating taking victory
laps on the internet
but they'll be quiet again they'll be
quiet once the bear market ends and they
begin to realize this technology is real
and that people around the world are
adopting it so if you're a builder keep
your head down and stay focused if
somebody is chirping leave them alone
bear markets end and technology cycles
continue true innovation doesn't care
what people on the internet are saying
we saw that in 2000 saw it in 2008 and
my guess is we're gonna see it again hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time